[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money your everything your
relationships your mental health i'm
john deloney joined here by best-selling
author and good friend christy wright
and we are taking your calls on
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five the ramsay show triple
eight eight two five five two two five
christie doing well i'm doing great it's
friday i'm always i'm always in a good
mood on friday who's not right standing
outstanding even if you love your work
friday's fun you're kicking off the
weekend yeah exactly all right let's go
to daryl in minneapolis minneapolis
minneapolis we are off to such a strong
start here people
reading reading reading what's up daryl
hey there how are you guys doing
remarkable how are you
good um so i had a question about
contributing to
to my retirement and cash flowing school
okay i'm just about to start
my fnp program family nurse practitioner
and i'm planning on cash flowing it all
the way good for you
yeah
so
so first year is all didactic and i
should be able to cover it no problem
second year is a lot of clinical work
and i'm looking at possibly having to
reduce my hours at work
in order to make the clinical section
work which makes which would make
you know cash flowing my
degree a little bit more challenging i
was just wondering you know
what is like the best option in terms of
like
you know
should i hold off on contributing
to retirement for that one year just to
kind of give myself a little extra
breathing room where are you working
right or just
so i work as an er nurse
in the minneapolis area and how how old
are you daryl
28th okay give us some more details
about your financial situation do you
have any debt
um so i have no debt besides my mortgage
125 000.
right now i have about 45 000 in savings
that includes my emergency fund
in terms of my retirement account i have
about 60 000
in a
roth and 401k and then i have about
275 000
in another retirement account so let me
ask you this i just i'm trying to run
these scenarios in my mind because just
at first glance it doesn't sound like
you really have to sounds like you might
want to to have some margin had some
breathing room as you described it does
it sound like you have to what's the
difference um if you stopped
contributing for whatever period of time
in order for you to make
make sure that you can cash flow this
like what amount of money are we talking
about have you added that up to the
total um so right now i contribute you
know about 400 to my 401k and then i max
out my roth every year
so
you know
you know the way i have my budget set
it's pretty tight
just to
do with school it's about
22 000 a year so
you know yeah i touch my things too much
i
i think the most important thing christy
hopping here i think the most important
thing here is to get through this
program debt-free
and so if you can cash for that great
if that means for a year two years
you're gonna pause you're gonna max out
the roth but you're gonna pause on that
400 a month or a 401 contribution or
you're going to end up pausing for two
years on all of your retirement to get
this
new position and the difference between
an er nurse and a nurse practitioner is
that what you're going to school for
right
correct yeah that i mean the pay
difference is significant right um
you'll make that money back up on the
back end i just want you to do whatever
it takes to not
go into debt i have had students of mine
who might
when they go to get into clinical
rotations they may even
go if they can go part-time in their
clinical rotations and extend the
programming year in order to stay out of
debt
yeah and not every program can do that
but i'm okay with that yeah here's the
thing darryl you are in a great
financial situation because you're
already committed to going to school
debt free you have no other debt you
have 45 000 in savings or whatever you
said so you're already in a great spot
whatever you do you're going to be fine
the thing that i want everyone to hear
anyone listening right now that is kind
of maybe in a similar similar shoes
you're like ah should i pause retirement
for this or should i you know uh make
this decision here to give me some
breathing room that's the only thing
that gave me a head tilt because i want
you to be in a situation where if you
can contribute you do now if you can't
and that's going to put you in a
position where you can't graduate
debt-free like like john's saying then
absolutely you can pause retirement and
come jump right back in you're going to
be in a great spot either way
but some people will sometimes say oh
well i need to dip into my emergency
fund because i need a little extra
wiggle room it's like well you know if
you need to sure do it if you don't have
to it doesn't hurt to to continue um
contributing to your retirement as well
so you're going to be in a good spot
either way and uh congratulations
congratulations on going to school
sounds like you are working really
really hard and i know it's going to pay
off i absolutely love that
going into school i think it's always
important and she's done it and i can't
everyone to hear this she's done the
math
this is not a prayer
we'll figure it out right there is no
guessing how much will the tuition cost
the room and board cost the fees cost
how much money do i have how much money
do i make let's make a budget let's make
a two and three year plan because that's
how long this program is the number of
college students i've met with over the
years who seem surprised year two like
i've got just enough money for year one
but that year year two's gonna come
right so plan for it right right good
for you good for you good for you yeah
way to go asking the right questions
that's awesome yes and hey as we run up
to the break i'm excited for this the
new questions for humans cards are out
i create i created these cards here's
what they are they are non-coveted
non-politics these are questions for you
and your friends when y'all are hanging
out questions for you you are trying to
reconnect with your spouse
there are deck of cards and questions
for kids that are multi-generational you
can sit with grandparents and little
ones you can sit around a table this is
for the holidays this is for driving oh
my gosh these are the these are perfect
for the holidays
okay so true or false you have not
looked at these since i've submitted the
plastic okay after the break at some
point today i'm asking you some of these
questions and i can't wait to see what
the questions are and can't wait to see
your response it's gonna be fun no i'm
super dude i'm so excited and the
reviews are coming back that are
fantastic one with my favorite
say who this is for specifically so the
most common thing i get is this let's
have it all right delaney we turned all
the screens off
i'm staring at my four daughters around
the coffee table and they're all looking
at me like now what dad yes or now with
mom or i
am picking up my young son
and then i drive through
the next pickup line and there's 30
minutes between when i pick up my son i
pick up my daughter
and i just ask my son like hey how was
school and he goes fine right and we're
all filling up we just stare at each
other yeah and so over the last 24
months we have lost we've lost it way
before that but it's easy to poke in the
last 24 months we've lost the ability to
just connect with one another yeah and
so these are
decks of cards there's three of them you
can go to john dillinger.com or
ramsolutions.com
it is three decks of cards that are not
about politics yeah not about hey man
what do you think about the vaccine
there is no vaccine questions they are
not controversial
they could be controversial well
different kind what's the thing
what is the thing you wish i did around
the house more and i am getting i am
getting comments back especially from
wives saying oh i've been wanting to
tell my husband this for years and now i
can just say oh it's in the game i gotta
answer it that's not my fault so yes
we'll ask each other questions
throughout uh today i can't wait it's
gonna be a good time hey
eight eight two five five two two five
we're taking your calls on anything and
everything your money your relationships
your life we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to matthew in baltimore maryland
what's up matthew
hey thank you for taking my call you got
it brother what's up
uh i am about 15 years old and i have
about 20 000
um i'm kind of kind of wondering what to
do with my money how'd you get twenty
thousand dollars at fifteen
uh i've been working for a long time i
work a lot
what do you do man
i here's what i'm asking you most adults
in the united states statistically
speaking don't have twenty thousand
dollars you are already in rare air and
you can't even buy cigarettes yet so
what have you been doing
[Laughter]
um
well when i was really young i started
working with my dad as i got older
i started mowing lawn and now i have a
little uh landscaping business
um i also like do i work part-time at a
restaurant little objects here and there
and just do whatever i can to make as
much money as possible you are a
go-getter matthew that's incredible what
a stud
all right so
you want to know what to do with this
money
yeah so i have about 12
250 give or take um in cash savings
right now okay
i also have a brokerage account with my
dad it's a custodial brokerage account
um
and we did a lot of research i don't
know eight nine months ago and started
investing i started investing a piece of
what i make every month
um i now have about 7 700 in there with
the interest added to it um
and now i'm kind of sitting here and i
don't know what to keep doing i don't
know if i should keep investing in those
index and mutual funds i'm in i don't
know if i should just save all of my
money
i don't know what to do well the fact
that you're asking about investments at
your age is incredible yes and the fact
that you're starting investing this
early is incredible you're going to have
a lot of money in your life matthew just
by the sheer
drive and habits and the the the foot
that you're starting out on here's what
i do want to remind you and you can
maybe tell me what your plan is for this
you got some expenses coming up most
likely potentially a car i don't know if
you're planning to go to college
a house maybe get so like in the next 10
years of your life you could have some
major expenses have you thought through
what you want to do for a vehicle or do
you have one or college if you want any
further education what's your plan there
yeah so i'm pretty uh planned out so for
the vehicle
my dad told me he would go half and half
with me we've had that conversation okay
um i decided that or we decided through
our conversations that with the market
right now what i have what he has
everything uh we're gonna go for about
twelve thousand dollars for a total for
the car
um so i'm not looking to buy a car until
late next summer like say august maybe
even september
because that's when i'll be getting my
license so i'll just need 6 000 saved up
by then which obviously i already have
that money yep awesome as far as moving
on towards college i just want to go
full time with my landscaping business
out of high school and then do community
college at night i don't really want to
go to a university
um i also am lucky enough that well
lucky in a way when i was really young
my mom passed away and we have a
some kind of money
i don't know what it's called
um that is through the government that
my dad does not use some kind of
assistance that he refuses to use
but he puts it in an account and his
intent there was that i could use it for
college if i wanted to gotcha oh cool
i believe there's right around 75 to 100
000 in there so it would hopefully take
care of most of my college tuition yeah
for sure well you are a planner matthew
well done so can i ask you a sideways
question and then we'll get to your
money answer
of course what do you do for fun
um i go out with friends
um
i like to go to the gym and work out
um nothing crazy though okay
i
your drive is incredible
and you're
um thinking things through
like i'm i'm just smiling here christy i
don't know adults who've planned the
next two or three years like you have
um
you're an incredible young man
and i want to make sure you have
relationships in your life and you've
got joy in your life too that you're
taking time to be goofy to act 15 and to
laugh and to make memories as well
you can mow your you can mow a bunch of
yards and man i tell you what i mowed a
ton of yards in high school i don't
remember any of them maybe one or two
i remember the laughter and the fun okay
so remember to have relationships enjoy
when it comes to your money i'm with
christy i like the idea of you
even if it's 30 bucks 25 bucks you
started this index mutual [ __ ] that's
fine and you've already i would tell you
to start a college savings account
you've already got that
um i would keep as much of this stuff at
15 liquid as possible you're not trying
to
earn a jillion bucks the 50 bucks you're
going to earn an interest on x dollar
you're going to be better spent being
able to go buy that car to be able to go
write a check for your books and your
first semester of community college
tuition whatever those things look like
and so i would keep that stuff as liquid
as possible through graduation
the goal is to get through
your your
your associate's degree whatever
certificates you want to get completely
debt free and that's when you're going
to loop right back into the baby steps
and you're going to start investing 15
of your income you start saving for
house you can start doing some of those
things and you're just on a you're just
on an accelerated path
and so it's going to be tempting to
overthink it because you plan ahead and
you move so quickly and remember you're
playing a long long game here don't
overthink it don't be like you know what
i'm just gonna put all bitcoin where you
are doing the right things brother um
get through the next five six years of
your life completely debt-free
continue your practice putting a little
bit of the stuff in in index funds and
then you'll be ready to rock and roll
yeah i think one of the other things
just to remind you i'm sure you already
do this matthew it sounds like you are
on top of everything but just keep your
personal finances and your business
finances separate and this may have
started as started as a small little
thing but the more sophisticated you get
with your landscaping business and if
you take it full time you're going to
want to have all those records records
for taxes for any equipment purchases
you want to make and you just want to
know what's your money what's your
business's money what are the business
expenses and so on and so
some of that money coming from the
business can stay in the business in the
business savings account for those
future equipment purchases as you scale
up your business and you'll be ready for
it because you're you're working hard in
your saver so great job and matthew i
just thought of one more thing even
though i said i was done yeah you got
one more second
of course yeah all the time you have are
you
do you have a regular practice of giving
i do yeah good who's somebody you give
to
um i give away i give stuff to my
friends and i buy them food and
everything all the time and i also um
last year i started this this year i'm
gonna do it much bigger but last year
around christmas i gave away about 500
to a charity okay um this year i'm
hoping to do like a couple thousand to
be honest with you excellent so give in
to your buddies buddies will just leech
on people like you they're gonna always
like you always dude he'll
matthew's got us dude he'll you'll be
you're paying for you're doing the job
don't let them become leeches on you
okay that's separate that's separate and
apart from
a regular practice of giving and again
we're playing a long-term game here both
with accumulating wealth and then
getting to the root of why do we even
earn money and that's so that we can
um have our safety here but we can give
generously and almost recklessly we just
give giveaway giveaway start that
practice now man that's that's another
key component to having a good financial
future yeah well done you're incredible
you're off to an amazing start all right
we got a minute left pulling up let's do
this i'm ready questions for humans go
to john delaney.com save your marriage
and your holidays i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask you one of the kids questions this
is fun what is the grossest thing in the
whole wide world knowing the things that
you talk about i just can't even imagine
what you would say for this oh man the
grossest thing in the whole wide world
you wrote this question can i tell you i
don't know if i'm ready for it no it's
not going to be as bad as you think when
i was a young child and this is me
shaming my mom on the radio great she's
my mom used to tell me john you're so
cute and you're so smart and i love you
but your feet are so disgusting
gross feet yeah i think i was married
for three years before my wife saw my
she's like
like i wore socks here
oh my gosh and so whenever i see other
humans feet it literally gives me the
heebs like my body yeah there you are on
the cover of your book i can't even look
at the cover of your book because of
your bare feet
i just came here today to gross john
dillon
cover of my book take back human feet
where i am barefoot or just just give me
the what about you what's the grossest
thing oh
gosh i don't know i feel like when i
became a mom my threshold for gross went
like out the window oh yeah you could be
on the phone throw up on me sure
whatever
oh look
half of the diaper caught half of that
the other half is all over me great i
tell you what ironically telling you
this
i don't love bathroom humor it's one of
your top favorite things i think it's
hilarious i don't even laugh at it a
little bit i'm like come on get more
creative this is my wife than that she
doesn't think any of it's funny kelly's
got me kelly's got me back there that is
not good company that is not good
company triple eight eight two five five
two two five questions for humans we're
answering everything right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
james told me i'm a little bit amped up
today
i'm just excited have a good time on the
radio
but i'm going to bring it down a notch
and just in time
is it too soon to start talking about
christmas
i know thanksgiving's still a couple of
weeks away but here's the deal me and
the rest of the ramsey solutions team
are already in a christmas frame of mind
and a big reason is we're already giving
away cash as part of our christmas cash
giveaway
every year we celebrate christmas with
our ramsay show listeners with our
ramsay christmas cash giveaway it's a
tradition now if you do it more than one
year in a row it's a tradition and this
year we're giving away 500 bucks every
week in a grand prize of 5 000
you can enter every day to increase your
chances of winning just text cash to
three three seven eight nine that's cash
to three three seven eight nine and you
can go ahead and get on the in on the
giving two we've got all kinds of
life-changing gifts for your family and
friends and our famous 10 sale that
means you can shop over 40 of our
best-selling books and envelopes for
just 10 bucks or less you can get books
like my number one bestseller
redefining anxiety dave's that little i
forgot the name of what's that little
book he wrote oh the total money
makeover yeah that one um you can get
rachel cruz's newest book you can get
christy wright's best-selling book
tons of them 10 bucks this year forget
the one-time use presents and get a life
give a lifetime worth of hope with a
gift go to shop the dollar sale at
ramseysolutions.com let's go to lisa in
pittsburgh what is up lisa how are we
doing
good how are you outstanding how can we
help
okay question for you um i use my
vehicle for work and i drive four to
five hundred miles a week it's a 2008
and i have 205 000 miles on it um my
boss pays for all the repairs and upkeep
and all that
so
i need a new vehicle
[Music]
and
he was going to give me 10 000 towards a
new vehicle
and he said i can do with it what i want
so 4 500 on this
vehicle
still and i have 3 800 in credit cards
so i'm wondering what the best way to
spend that 10 000
did he give you money for a new car and
say this needs to be for a new car
because that's a real big deal if he
gave you money toward the car for the
car because you use the car for work
he said i could do with it what i wanted
but it was to try to help me out to get
a vehicle with lesser miles
is he
how much has you spent in repairs on
your current car this year
how much has he spent um i am not sure
about that he pays for my oil changes
tires i just recently had to put like
1700 into it
it's getting to the point where it's
kind of nickel and diming you to death
yeah i i just wonder if he's being
altruistic or if he is doing this as a
business investment on his own right
right he just sees the writing on the
wall here's ten thousand dollars get
yourself a little bit of an upgrade yeah
because he if he gave you that money
because he wants you to be in a good
dependable car that's not nickel and
diming you
at the end of this
and you're not because you put that
money towards debt he's gonna be
frustrated that's what i'm right as
would anybody be yeah or he's going to
you're going to pay off all of your debt
it's going to be debt-free and next week
the transmission's going to fall out of
your car and you're going to go to him
and say hey you said you're going to
cover this and he's going to say i just
gave you ten thousand dollars
and actually
i wish that would do it but well the
thing is
my payments right now on this are 216 a
month i can't
afford four to six hundred dollars a
month for a vehicle so i'm kind of in a
catch 22. so my reasoning was if i paid
off that 3800 credit card debt then that
frees up some cash flow for me
um
you know yeah
here's you got a ten thousand dollar
check and you're trying to come up with
some really cool ways yeah the shell
game
make it work so you can keep it
um you feel like you won the lottery you
didn't you got ten thousand dollars to
get a new car
um right well obviously yeah how much is
that your broken down car how much is it
worth
um i'm guessing around seven thousand
and i have 4 500 on it i would sell it
before the day is over and then buy a
thirteen thousand dollar car
and
tell your boss you're grateful for um
his or her investment in you and then
get on and then you got a
uh thirty eight hundred dollars of
uh credit card credit card debt you're
gonna get that knockout you said that
wasn't it what else do you have what
else what other kind of debt
oh
i don't know if you want to know are you
calling you called and you know it's
called the ramsay show
you know what i'm gonna ask let's have
it what do you got first people unless
you're listening to that 15 year old i'm
kind of embarrassed
you're gonna have to get in line behind
that 15 year old man he's way ahead of
most people so what's up
um
well i have my house i owe like 77 000
on my house um other than that we're not
talking about house mainly just consumer
debt here yeah
um like windows in my house does that
count uh
i had i owe 55 on that but there's no
interest on it um 55 000 or 500.
okay and then you got 45 on your car
that you're gonna sell today what else
do you got you got windows that you owe
money on
you've got
student loans
oh well
there's no my daughter i have a student
loans in my name but it's my daughter's
and yeah
it's got your name on it how much is
that
43 000.
how much do you make every year
does she make no you
me 57
and i have two kids at home
income
yep okay
um yeah if i'm you by the end of this
day i owe
thirty hundred dollars in credit cards
and fifty five hundred dollars in my
windows i'm gonna get those credit cards
taken care of as fast as humanly
possible even if i have to pick up
another job or ask my boss if i can make
another shift or another drive or
whatever and
before the middle of next year i'm going
to have that knocked out
and then it's just going to be versus
those windows and you're get the stress
of not having a car payment and the
stress of having a car that you're not
worried about breaking down on you all
all the time is going to let you sleep
just uh two percent deeper
i'm not i miss that like what am i
supposed to do about a vehicle then oh
you go buy one with that ten thousand
dollars
you're kidding me you've heard me a ten
thousand dollar card that doesn't have a
hundred thousand miles long or more
so i i don't think i don't and i put 500
on a week i don't understand how i'm
going to find a car that cheap
that
i'm not in the same position i'm in
right now you said your car's got 200
000 miles on it
205 305. so yeah you're trading in for a
hundred thousand miles what kind of what
kind of car do you have
uh toyota highlander
okay
you may downsize in car you may downsize
in brand it may not be your dream car
but you absolutely can find a good
used moderate mileage car for under 10
000. people do it every day you're going
to do some digging you may have to look
outside of your neighborhood your city
you might have to negotiate you can find
a tv
because i drive one it's not an absurd
don't give me that yeah i drive one the
other thing lisa that i hear in your
story and i just want to say this before
we go to break
you're not working the plan
no you're not you're trying to move
things around and hoping that moving
things around or skipping steps or
dodging things or find different way
because shortcuts is going to get you to
where you want to be it won't
it won't you have to work the plan you
have to commit to stop digging yourself
in more debt stop accepting that
payments are our way of life stop
looking for shortcuts
get your thousand dollars and then dig
away at your debt and don't give up
until you get out of debt you i hear it
in your voice you're okay with those
payments and as long as you're okay with
those payments you will never do
anything different and you will never
get anywhere different and as long as
your attitude is oh just ten thousand
dollars what am i gonna do with that you
can change everything lisa
everything with ten thousand dollars and
is it gonna be your dream card no
no
it's gonna be something that's gonna get
you another 24 months down the road or
36 months down the road
so one person will call and say i've got
ten thousand dollars i can make this go
so far i could be so smart with this
someone else calls and goes that's not
enough can't do anything with that
attitude matters how you view the amount
of money because it's going to determine
what you do with it yes and so let me
say let me say this in a different way
you're in an emergency situation you got
two young kids you got a car that's
falling apart and you owe 43.
50 55 000
this is an emergency take the 10 000 buy
the car get yourself down the road and
get this debt paid off start working the
plan this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your calls on money life relationships
everything let's go to anna in h town
houston hey anna what's going on
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely what's going on how can i
help
and i'm going to seek advice in regards
to
my death i have 110 000 dollars in debt
and i own the ir is 35 000
so i would like to know i know that i
have to follow the snowball
and
reform but i would like to know if i
have to pay the irs first and then go
back to the snowball or how can i
how can i do it
yes
you want to get the irs off your back
okay what is what what's the give us the
numbers what's the you have 110 plus 35
no including
all right and what's the rest of that
debt
in
car loan cell phone
personal loans credit cards
you name it so you're just pretty much
normal right how much is your car loan
yeah
and the car loan right now is like 12
000. okay
how much do you make a year
i make anywhere between
55 to 75.
55 to 75. are you married
hey i recently got married two weeks ago
oh congratulations
so thank you how much does
your partner make
he makes between 35 to 40 000. okay how
much debts he got he has no debt
okay so combined y'all are about 80 to
110 right
yes
and now
you got to got to got to get this irs
off your back
asap all
get that off and i know we have the baby
steps and we talk about going in order
there but you got to get rid of that irs
debt
okay so put everything else on pause and
just attack the irs yeah yeah you want
to get that out of here and then you'll
work the debt snowball like normal where
you list your debts from smallest to
largest by balance regardless of
interest rate and then you will knock
those out but yeah you got to get
serious with that one that's not one you
want to drag out that's not one you want
to have any problems with have you have
you and your new husband have you all
been through financial peace university
to class
no okay so our wedding gift to you
congratulations we're gonna i'm gonna
give you a year's worth of ramsay plus
subscription for free so stay on the
line here and we'll get you a
subscription there and i want you and
your husband here's the thing though
it's a it's an expensive gift we're
giving you
you all have to commit to going through
all nine lessons and this is going to
set your entire marriage up for success
and it's going to walk you through how
do we get out of this giant 110 000 hole
that we've started our marriage in as
quickly as possible is that cool
yes thank you very much i really
appreciate it do i have your commitment
you're gonna work through it
yes excellent i love it love it love it
all right congratulations and yeah next
step let's get it going but get the irs
out of your life
forever because they'll be back in april
for more let's go to antonio in phoenix
hola antonio what's up
hey how you doing excellent how are you
doing good thank you
so what's up so the reason i called in
is um i was basically looking for some
advice
um i've been i'm a pretty huge uh
automotive enthusiast and
i know you guys always say um don't
finance buying cash and so i've been
saving up for quite a while and i ended
up purchasing one of the dreams one of
my dream cars
and um what'd you get now i'm kind of in
i bought a
skyline gtr
i don't even know
[Laughter]
i don't even know what that is antonio
how much did it cost
it cost me uh 41. okay so like give or
take a toyota camry
[Laughter]
give give or take maybe like a prelude
oh okay all right okay so you're one of
those guys all right so
yeah you got this car you paid for it in
cash
yes sir outstanding man all right so
what's up thank you
so now i'm kind of in a tough financial
situation because
i did just blow um
40 something
yes sir how much do you make and um
how much do i make i make 35 a year
antonio oh okay what are you doing
brother
does that feel wrong as you say it out
loud
does that feel wrong in the same breath
i paid 41 000 for a car and i make
thirty five thousand feel
it doesn't feel wrong because i bought
it in cash okay
it should
it should that just means your radar's
out of tune
but we're here to help right you did it
close to right so good for you yes
partially right
yes you did it less wrong so we'll high
five you
um are you going to ask us should you
sell this yes and the answer is yes
tell the car yes you don't have the
money you don't have money here's the
deal antonio if you were making a
hundred thousand dollars a year you were
completely debt free you had all your
investments had worked the baby steps
you had everything else on track and you
wanted to pay cash for a 41 000 car cool
yeah that's a very different scenario
than the one that you're in
you just yes you saved up in cash but
you weren't ready for that you can't
afford that in other areas of your life
which you
called in explaining do you have other
debt brother
i do not i'm debt-free okay um
do you where do you live
i live in phoenix arizona do you have
any like a house or an apartment or
something like that
oh gotcha uh i live in a townhouse okay
do you have an emergency fund
as of now i use my emergency fund to
divide the gtr
and there's problem number two antonio
that car wasn't an emergency
you were doing great with your savings
you had an emergency fund if an
emergency were to happen now you're
struggling paying bills making ends meet
if an emergency occurred you would have
had that fund to pay for that's what
it's for not for the dream car i'm not
saying you can't have the dream car one
day i think you can i think you will but
using your emergency fund for it was not
wise and yes you need to sell it you put
that money back in savings you need to
get your income up save some more save
and save and save and save and when your
income is up and you have a really good
savings above and beyond your emergency
fund for a car then sure buy you a car
you just you try to you try to skip some
steps and do it a little faster cars
should not be more than half of your
annual income
at the apps and
in my house we're way way way below that
way below that
um to avoid this exact scenario we're
talking about yeah
because it's indicative of of having
your your your strategy backwards that
we're going to pay more for a car than
we make in a whole year in a whole year
even if you saved and paid cash for it
so
yes you were hey but here's what you
proved you proved you can work really
hard yep and safe you can save
and you can put your eyes on a goal so
yeah your goal is going to be having a
fully funded emergency fund and making
more than 35 000 a year i'll see you
using that willpower and that grit and
determination and go crank it up and get
that income up and go from there man
41
all right let's do another question
we're running up against the clock here
let's do one more okay
questions for humans john delaney.com or
ramseysolutions.com these are your
family savers do what james
okay i thought james is gonna come in
with one too he's gonna embarrass me
okay i'm ready i got one for you all
right which one is this
these are for kids okay there's three
decks there's one for for couples
one for
um that you can do with your kids for
multi-generation so i'm thinking about
christmases where all anybody wants to
talk about is the latest conspiracy
theory youtube clip or covid and this is
gonna give everybody from grandparents
to children something a new way to learn
and talk to each other and there's
another one for
uh friends you just y'all are all out
having drinks and this helps grease the
wheels there so go for it okay um i just
changed my i got several here i'm gonna
ask you throughout the throughout the
day but here's i like this one what's
your what was your favorite birthday
oh man
i love birthdays i'm like a high eye on
the disc i've got some enneagram seven
in me i love to celebrate so i get
excited about holidays and birthdays
what was your favorite
well this is gonna be a cheesy answer
but it's the truth my favorite one was
my
24th birthday because i surprised i
invited all my friends to my birthday
and then i
surprised my wife by asking her to marry
me on my birthday oh that's so totally
that should be your favorite anything
else would be amazing my mom makes a
dope cake so those all the i was
thinking all the cakes she made were
good but yeah that was a great birthday
that was fun that's a really good one
what about you what's your favorite
birthday um
[Music]
i don't know you don't even know
i mean i i love them all for different
reasons oh i know i take it back last
summer a couple of couples we went to
the lake house and did an adult only
couples weekend no kids went tubing
riding the boat staying outside it was
awesome hey
questions for humans give us a call
triple 825-5225 it's an hour in the book
we'll be right back on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money your life
your relationships your mental health
your small business anything and
everything i'm john deloney joined here
by christy wright and we are talking to
you good folks about whatever's on your
mind give us a shout triple eight eight
two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to john out
in flint michigan what's up brother john
hey thanks for singing my call um
so i'm actually kind of in a
bad mental state and
kind of got thrown into a situation
where
it kind of put my family behind um so i
kind of dug myself more in debt
what's going on
about two months ago i got laid off from
my job because
um
they weren't really willing to work with
my schedule needing to take care of my
wife and my kids due to my wife having a
neurological disorder
um so they laid me off i was able to
pick up a job really quickly but i had
to wait a month
to pick back up
now with the new job
i'm making a little bit more hourly but
i'm also losing out on a bonus
so i'm kind of losing money so um
i'm just kind of
in its rough spot trying to get myself
back on my feet and my family back on
their feet
um and not really sure where to go
because my schedule with work now kind
of puts me in a situation where i can't
pick up a second job sure um so let's
back up a little bit
is your
number one you got a lot going on just
want to honor you for a second and just
say
it's a lot
man your wife's struggling she's hurting
your kids are
kids are just kids how old are they
uh seven and three yeah you're in it man
you are you are all in it everything
from is god real to changing diapers
still nick you are in it right
um i guess you're not changing diapers
at three anymore but who knows
um when you say your family's behind
or
you're losing money i want you to
expand on that a little bit are you do
you have enough money to pay your bills
or
have you all just got behind for a month
and it's just gonna take some time to
catch up is this an existential behind
or is this a we don't have enough money
for food behind
um it was uh we don't have enough money
for food behind but
um my mother-in-law did step in to help
me with a couple grand not a couple
grain but a couple hundred dollars
um to help us buy some food um
but a lot of
what ended up being was put onto
a credit card which threw us about three
grand deeper into that okay you you you
you had a hurricane hit you and you
survived and so what's done is done and
there's appeared to the end of that
sentence
what does today look like do you have do
you make enough money to pay your bills
yeah um i'll be making
i think 95
between 75 and 95
a year now with the new job
um so i mean i'll i'll be able to float
but i'm also i mean just in student
loans alone i'm almost
350 000 in debt
what did you take out 315 000 in student
loans for
so i was a
i got my law degree okay um i have not
passed my state bar
this was a couple years ago i graduated
um
but with life and everything i haven't
been able to study and take the bar
again
but i'm a mortgage underwriter and i am
doing well with that yeah there's a lot
a lot of lawyers not making that kind of
money
yeah and your wife can't work right
she's got neurological challenges yes
with neurological disorder i mean she
has her own business she does um
do cosmetic stuff with her
with her own business
but it's only been open for a couple
years so it's been a negative for the
most part
but i mean she is trying to do more with
that now okay
um the reality is yeah you're in a hard
hard situation and
at some point you're gonna have to
make the shovel bigger it sounds right
now like it sounds like right now y'all
are gonna have to survive for a season
do y'all have family nearby at all
um we have families by but they're not
really able to help any
okay
the thing that the thing that's jumping
out to me john is here asking all the
details about this is um
you need some support john yeah you need
some break a break and i don't know
where that comes in i don't know if it's
help with the kids help with your wife
help with both someone to help your wife
help her business become profitable she
she doesn't have a business she has a
hobby right now it's losing money i
think it could become profitable right
now it's actually draining your bank
account instead of enhancing it i don't
know what her capacity is but she had
help help she may be able to actually
contribute to the income especially if
she enjoys doing it but i i just i think
you need help like
you cannot do this by yourself you're
making a good income and and yes you can
tackle this debt but the shortest route
between
you and being debt-free with everything
you've got going on uh is going to be to
get some help in your corner and um and
i don't know what that looks like that's
where i i just don't have it there
there's really no one to kind of help or
support or anything like that are there
any resources from like the medical
community in your area or church
community i mean i'm let's think outside
the box here because i do believe
there's some help maybe we just haven't
explored a creative outlet for that
it that john when i hear we've reached
out yes um i mean we reached out to my
daughter's school they go to a
a church a losing school
um they said that been looking to help
us get like kind of sponsored there
haven't heard anything back on that
um we reached out to our church they
really weren't in a situation to really
help us really at all either
um
my here here's john here
i mean it's it's just one of those
things i mean but listen listen listen
listen the only thing i really haven't
looked into was my va kind of help
are you you're a veteran as well
yes
yes so
here's what it sounds like a guy who is
exhausted and overwhelmed
am i fair
is that fair very much so
okay
even saying i owe 300 something thousand
dollars in student loans i make upwards
of 95 000 a year and um
i have a lot i'm smart enough to get
through law school i've struggled with
the bar that's fine lots of brilliant
people do
um
and i don't know how we're going to make
ends meet but i got to keep my kids in
private school there's just some hard
conversations some hard realities you
have to face that we're still we're
still running a makeup uh cosmetic surg
uh cosmetic business but it's failing
you all have to have some hard hard
conversations in your home you my
brother need to and you've reached a
point where those conversations are all
taking place at the exact same time in
your head and it's overwhelming
you're starting to feel like you're
drowning am i right
yep yes so here's the bravest strongest
thing you can do in this season of your
life is go find somebody to talk to
whether that's a mentor whether that's a
friend that you trust whether that's a
counselor you can say i don't have
enough money i'm telling you right now
you don't have enough money not to
go sit down with somebody and what
they're gonna walk you you just need
somebody to sit with for a second and
begin to pull all these thoughts that
are looping and looping and looping and
spin and spin begin to pull them apart
and say is this true or is this not
is this your reality forever is this
your reality for right now yes one 1 000
i know you want to stay away from the va
they've got resources for you give them
a call
if you don't call them that's your pride
talking and we need to put that aside
and start dealing with some of these
emergencies here and like christy said
people may not be able to help you with
cash but they might be able to help you
with your time
they may be able to just let you and
your wife go on a walk write a list of
what you need what specific tactical
help do you need and then start looking
for people to fill those gaps i think
sometimes when you're overwhelmed you
don't know what you need
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john deloney
joined by my good friend the
best-selling author christy wright we're
taking your calls on life and money
relationships small businesses
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five gracie we talked about
another hour the questions for humans is
here
i'm so excited about this because i love
i love fun conversations and this is
literally this this another subtitle
could be fun conversation starters
because yes you just ask such
interesting questions that
bring fun conversations to life i love
it thank you so
if we talked about this previously this
comes from a conversa like so many folks
have written into my show saying
all right so we're doing all the stuff
you say we are all getting together and
having connection time and no screens
and we have no screens and now we're
just staring at each other we don't know
what to do next or we just keep talking
and all it ends up talking about is
politics and drama and crap and so we
created
three decks of cards they're called
questions for humans there's one for
friends you and your buddies just going
out to have a drink chips and salsa
you're grabbing a cigar you're just
going to talk and you're going to pull
these things out this is a good way for
people who don't know how to
be vulnerable with each other can be
like oh it's got to answer the question
bro and it's helpful or just couples are
going out with other couples and there's
one for
people who are romantic with one another
and they have had the last 24 months and
they're not so romantic anymore
and we are staring at each other and
we're tired of talking about our kids
and mask policies and your opinions on
the vaccine but there is no covet no
politics just had to reconnect and then
we got another deck of cards that i
envisioned for
moms and dads and pickup lines at
schools
just trying to engage in conversations
with their kids it's multi-generational
so grandparents can talk to their
their grandkids around the thanksgiving
table stocking stuffers whatever so a
lot of fun pull one out there and ask
one all right what i love this one what
does it mean to be cool
this one's for kids but i want you to
answer it what does it mean you're like
a grown-up kid sometimes strongly just
strongly disagree what does it mean to
be cool
it means
i know i'm really ready for you if i
answer
being cool means
i am secure in myself
and i don't
i
don't care what other people think about
the things that i'm currently doing i
could not agree more as if here
confidence just being you and being okay
that's a better
to me that is the coolest
absolutely yeah and so people think oh i
want to it's the leather jacket or it's
the shoes it's not it's how that
person's walking through a room yeah
yeah
that's cool my son carter one of his
best friends i mean these are
seven-year-olds but i've spent a lot of
time with him and he is so
he's not the coolest kid in the class
i'm doing air quotes here of like i
don't think he's like you know the most
popular he is so confident though and to
me he is absolutely the coolest when
you're around he's just like yeah i'm
just me like he's just he's not trying
to impress anybody he's just good with
whatever
my son rolls like that yes i'll say how
do you leave the house
looking like that shirt's inside out
here's all and he's like that's cool man
yeah and i feel like i'm good with it i
would love to be as
cool as my kid that's so cool all right
let's go to louis in
san jose california what's up louis
hi john hi christie thank you for
repeating my call
um thank you so much both of you i love
all your shows in the big uncle ramsey
show so i mean maybe step two and um
just about to complete the last uh
student loans that i have twenty
thousand all right congratulations by
the way i
thank you by the way i hope my accent
doesn't get in the way you're
okay um
i wanted to ask we we just found out
about dave ramsey two years ago and we
were beginning to build our own house
and
i was ninety thousand dollars in debt
and you know he just messed me up so
i've been paying off the debt and i
completed building our house this uh
last august we dedicated the whole it
was 150 000 it's not in this country so
that's what more more but we want to
start a small business
and um
i'm hoping to complete the debt payment
in uh december end of december
so i was wondering um should i
invest in retirement put more money in
retirement
or invest in a smooth business that my
husband and i
want to invest in
and um
yeah that's that's my question and
the next question i had was
how do i take investments for a roth
account
because i just recently opened one and i
um
yes in a blackout
okay i have some follow-up questions
lois so i just want to make sure i'm
tracking with you here when you say you
have twenty thousand dollars left in
debt that has nothing to do with the
house right that's just consumer debt
yeah so yeah the twenty thousand dollars
i'm going to say is um
student loans about 16 000 and the last
credit card okay that i have about 4
000. okay and did you say that you paid
150 000 to build a house not in this
country
yes i uh we built our house in cash we
uh we were born raised in kenya so we
built a nice house in kenya we just
wanted to go back up and build something
nice back home
previously i had built a house for my
mother also
in cash so um
i was not following the beauty steps i
was just focused on
uh giving my family something better
than what i had when i grew up yeah no
that's great so where do you live here
so i live in sunnyvale i work
for stanford healthcare
do you live in a yeah do you own a home
here do you live do you rent
no so i moved from a house that was
costing us about five thousand dollars a
month to an apartment that cost me about
two thousand dollars a month
just um when i found out about about
dave landry so that has allowed me to
save quite a bit to
pay off a lot of debts
yeah okay
okay there's i just want to make sure
i've got all the details here because
there's a lot going on here are you
familiar with our baby step i know you
said you're familiar with with dave
ramsey are you familiar with our baby
steps in the order that they go in
yes i attended um fbu two years ago
and
i began to budget
but i was building i decided to build so
i'm budgeting for the building
with one thousand dollars in emergency
fund i think i had emergencies every
time sure
i could see that
i could see that well well i just wanna
you've got a couple kind of not
complicated but a couple different
situations here because of the house
you're talking about and so on but let's
just talk about today here in the united
states you in california
um you're really still in baby step
number two and so do you have a thousand
dollars like
somewhere set aside for some type of
emergency okay so we've got that yeah
that i have religiously yeah okay great
so you're going to pay off that last bit
of debt you said you're very close about
20 000 left and then you're going to be
debt free but there's still some things
that you want to do before
you save up to buy a house here
potentially um or before you start
investing in baby step four and that's
you're going to be in baby step three
where you save three to six months of
expenses in a savings account
above and beyond past this is after your
debt so you're going to build up that
thousand dollars to three to six months
of expenses and then you really just
need to make a decision at that point do
you want to
save up for a down payment on a house
or do you want to
invest in a business and i don't what
kind of business are you thinking about
starting
so we we want to start a hardware
business a hardware explorer okay um
yeah okay well that that's the type of
thing where that's going to take some
startup costs
i would still encourage you to think of
your kind of 1.0 version of your idea
but let's get out of debt get three to
six months of expenses saved up
and then and then you sit down with your
spouse and you have a conversation about
what the next goal is if you guys are
wanting to buy a house you might want to
go ahead and start saving for that and
figure out how you could start this
business the the smallest viable option
to prove your idea prove your concept
begin to serve the marketplace maybe you
maybe you sublease a corner of an
existing retail storefront you're not
taking on the overhead of a full uh
lease and that type of thing prove your
concept and start to build that business
on a small small scale um and then
you're just not having all that cost up
front while you get some cash in the
door prove the concept and then and then
you can gradually build it up but you're
doing great we just need to get that
emergency fund main thing right now yeah
and it sounds like you're scattered yeah
whenever you start feeling scattered
whenever i start feeling scattered i've
been doing this for years and even i
start feeling scattered
i always just got to go back to those
seven little simple steps yeah in order
i over complicate it and seem to get
right back in order right and not over
dramatizing over complicated and don't
take out money to start this hardware
business lois no you work too hard to be
debt-free congratulations on your
success we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show and we have a
beautiful person on the debt-free stage
pamela how are you doing i'm doing all
right how about yourself
god are you nervous a little bit you're
gonna do great you're doing great
already deloney's more nervous than you
don't even worry i assure you i am more
nervous than you yes okay so pamela
where are you from i'm originally from
puerto rico excellent yes i've been in
tennessee now six years we're so glad
that you're here awesome and then what
brought you to tennessee oh man uh
back home life is really hard okay uh so
i needed to be able to pursue
you know my career
um so i moved here just for
opportunities literally with a suitcase
and 500 in my bank account wow
what a story all right so how much have
you paid off twenty eight thousand eight
hundred and three dollars and how long
did that take you 18 months
whoa
how much were you making um at the
beginning i was making about 31 500. um
ended up with 45 at the end of this
awesome so
in that make it 45 000
so you paid off almost 30 grand 18
months that means you got after it
yes wow okay so what in the world
happened 18 months ago that you said
enough enough i'm freaking pamela it's
time
march 2020 oh okay yes um it was maybe
two weeks before the big shutdown here
in tennessee tell me what happened in
march of 2020 i don't remember is there
anything
wow okay so they shut down everything
yes um i work in mental health so we're
always open
and two days before payday
my car broke down and they asked for 975
to pay it off to fix it
and i looked at my bank account and i'm
like my credit cards are back like
completely maxed i don't have any money
i have to wait until payday
so i had to call out of work because i
could i didn't have a car to get to work
and i didn't have the money to fix it so
i had to ask my mom for money at 33.
that's terrible embarrassing um
and that kind of was just a stop i was
too afraid i was very afraid of what was
going on in the world and then this was
happening too and i was just i just had
it
so how did you get connected with us how
did you get uh connected with ramsay and
the plan and all that yeah i've always
been very frugal um but i've always
tried to figure out better ways to do it
i was just kind of ish before i even
knew i was ish okay um and
i had listened to one of his youtube
videos in the past about a year and a
half ago a year before i started this
whole thing
and
i heard him talk calling people stupid
and i'm like oh my gosh that's not me
i'm not gonna listen to this guy
and then come
you know fast forward um i had to sit
down with myself and say i don't care if
he's calling people stupid
um i didn't feel that i was being stupid
i was just trying to survive here yeah
um
but the reality is that it was still the
same effect i might not be stupid but
i'm still in debt and i need to fix this
you may not be stupid but your choices
aren't the aren't the best right there
you go right and so
march of 2020 comes
your snow globe just gets shaken six
ways to sunday
and you said no more what was your next
step um well i needed to fix my car that
was the first thing
and i knew that i needed to get a job
even though everything was shutting down
i needed to find that money
i looked around my house i don't have a
lot to sell
just because everything was like
secondhand and i'm like nobody's gonna
buy this so i knew that that meant for
me that i had to
sweat
this is going to be sweat equity
um so i started working with a cleaning
company
and a couple months later i decided to
open up my own business wow awesome and
is your is it a cleaning business or
something awesome so do you not work in
mental health anymore i do i do both you
do both well i guess
cleaning business is the mental health
business too yeah kind of yeah yes you
get to see some things doing that oh you
have no idea yes
wow so if you were to back out
and
and be talking to i don't know a couple
of million people like you are right now
what would you tell them
the key to getting out of debt is
i think the first thing you have to be
real about yourself just look yourself
in the mirror and really say we need to
fix this
this is not the way that we were
intended to live we were not put in this
earth to struggle the way that we are
right now so we need to fix it
um how did you bridge that gap because i
know a lot of mental health
professionals a lot of them i got a lot
of close friends yeah who are really
good at walking alongside other people
with their challenges but it's really
hard to look in the mirror how did you
make that turn because that's especially
hard for a mental health professional
honestly so you're gonna think this is
really um silly but i teach groups in
the hospital that i work at and um
i teach goal setting groups and i'm like
i'm looking at all my stuff
preparing for my classes and
i said i have all the information that i
need to do this so why why am i not
doing it
i don't
why
so that day i was just i just had enough
wow so
did people around you think you were
nuts a little who thought tell me who
you thought was crazy you thought you
were crazy um my family for sure they
were very skeptical um of me doing both
jobs
my co-worker livy she's here with me
today uh she was actually the first
person i told about my whole journey day
one
because i had to call her and let her
know hey i can't come to work can you
cover for me
um
yeah
who are your biggest cheerleaders libby
of course yes my coworkers i have a
little squad
my supervisor kayla
i have a lot of people that came up
along the way
that god put in my place there was no
reason for them to
bet on me but they did
so i'm forever grateful for my dixons my
greens
my nobles and my morrisons
that's amazing how does it feel i mean
you've got all the debt gone now and
you've worked so hard how does it feel
amazing i
for the longest time you know where i'm
from the man is the head of the
household
um so you don't have to worry about
finances but i'm here i'm 30 and i'm
single and i'm going uh oh i need to fix
this
yeah um and now i feel empowered yeah i
can do it i can do anything
i love
and it started with ownership and the
looking at the person in the mirror i
just love your attitude of like i am the
problem i'm the solution i'm going to
fix this and that that attitude has
carried you all the way through this
that's right and then you got some
people that walked alongside you held
you accountable yeah you could call on
the hard days so one of the most common
things we get is excuse after excuse
after excuse and i'm looking at a woman
who came to the united states six years
ago with a backpack
and dug yourself a hole and then you dug
yourself out of it what do you tell that
person right now who's looking is afraid
to look in the mirror who doubts
themself i can't do this i can't figure
this out you know what pray okay i was a
lost sheep when i got here um and this
whole process has just
led me to believe
you need to look at god you need to walk
closer to god
very cool all right pamela pamela from
puerto rico
via nashville tennessee that's right
paid off twenty eight thousand eight
hundred dollars in eighteen months
making
a little less than forty five thousand
dollars are you ready yes all right
count it down
three
two one i'm debt free
[Music]
that's awesome i love her she's so sweet
she's so sweet but i wouldn't i wouldn't
fight her
no i hope not no i mean
for the main reason is i wouldn't fight
her but great great start
that's a human being with determination
and grit and strength yes but i love the
attitude i love the personal
responsibility and you know what's so
interesting people may not realize this
but
when we answer calls all day when we
host the show we can often tell if
someone's actually going to do it or not
almost we give them this week
and be like not going to do it not going
to do it yeah or they're going to rock
everything's different and you can tell
in her voice had we talked to her 18
months ago when she started we would
have said oh yeah she's really going to
do it because you can tell the attitude
of ownership that's not the only
variable but that's a big one on whether
or not you feel in control of your
destiny your outcome controlling what
you can control and making it happen and
the people that believe they have some
level of control and they're gonna take
take the bull by the horns they go do it
they go move things they go make things
happen and i just gosh i love seeing
that example
and
i'm a guy that makes excuses and we're a
culture of people who make excuses yeah
and
it's when i come to work and somebody
like pamela just shows up and just takes
them all away
like i showed up on your doorstep six
months ago i'm six years ago with a
backpack what do you got to say for
yourself
yeah and i'm like well you know uh i had
a hard morning i didn't have enough
coffee uh
feeling bad about myself and uh like oh
cool i did this all by myself and i
crushed everything incredible and to
those of you who are walking alongside
people on their journey thank you too
yeah thank you to the friends and the
family and the community that is
cheering people on even if you think
they're nuts and if somebody's in your
life and they're telling you
oh man i'm gonna get debt free and
you're like what just watch them
just watch them change everything
because you can change too this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 this is the ramsey show and
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for
free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply
today's question comes from grace in
utah here's what grace writes my husband
has worked as an independent insurance
contractor for four years i joined the
business three years ago which is how i
met him i've been the sole income earner
for the past few years but recently
became a stay-at-home mom
my husband has been using my credit card
for basic necessities like gas food etc
he's made no income and has depleted our
emergency funds and roth ira just to pay
for our rent and basic living
necessities i love my husband very much
but he is not taking necessary steps to
take care of his family how do i help
him realize it's okay to look for other
sources of income or to step it up in
his business
whoa okay
yeah so okay um
not taking steps to take care of his
family it's an understatement of the
century he is burning your family he's
destroying you to the ground he's not
just not taking care of you he's
destroying you from the inside out he's
destroying your trust your
self-confidence your financial future
your current future
he's burning your family to the ground
how do i help him realize it's okay to
look for other sources of income it's
not okay he has to today
if your house was on fire
you wouldn't say i need to
i'll use your words how do i help my
husband realize it's that we probably
should head out into the front yard
because the house is on fire you would
start screaming hit every alarm
knock over furniture on the way to get
to your kids and get your husband and
get out in the yard that's where we're
at right now
there are so many there are so many
problems with this one of the things
that jumped out to me to the very
beginning of the question so he's been
an uh independent insurance contractor
for four years she joined the business
three years ago which is how she met him
and she's been the sole income earner
for the past few years
if three is few
he met her and hasn't been making any
money since or somewhere around that
time he's never made a penny and so
then then grace you became a
stay-at-home mom you can't become a
stay-at-home mom you don't have any
money to become a stay-at-home mom you
have no he's not making money and you're
not making any money yeah and your your
money's not combined either by the way
it has not stopped him from draining it
but when you say he he used your credit
card well there are so many problems i
feel like we need to
start at the beginning so grace here
hear us say
this is a
level one emergency this is a defcon one
you're on life support now you have no
money you're broke your husband has set
your house on fire
and you are not recognizing the severity
of where you are and i i actually think
you do
um i think you're brilliant otherwise
you wouldn't have been the sole i mean
you wouldn't have been successful here i
think you're smart i think you're strong
and i think
this has become so real that it's just i
mean it's become so acute that's almost
become a cartoon
and so what christian are telling you is
this is a
huge deal
you got to turn all the lights on turn
the music off this dance is over
and you all have to get very serious he
needs to go start working three jobs
this weekend and he needs to close this
nonsense business and y'all got to start
earning some money and the days of you
being a stay-at-home mom are probably
over too and what and what if he doesn't
like he's never made money in their
marriage right so
he's never proven that he's capable of
it or interested in it right so for that
and i'm i'm genuinely asking you john
because these are those hard
situations um i tell everybody in this
type of situation you have to have an or
what moment you have to have in your
head you've looked put both hands on
your counter and looked yourself in the
mirror and say or what
and that is
i'm going to tell my husband you will
never hit me again today
or what
i'm going to tell my son you will not
bring drugs into my house again or what
you've got to have that moment and this
is
financial abuse this is this is wrong on
every level and so at this point i've
got children i this is a scary situation
she's got to have her or what moment
and and i want to i want you to speak
into this too where one of the the close
to the last line says i love my husband
very much
but he's not taking the necessary steps
to take care of his family talk about
how love plays into this like i love
this person
so
i mean i know i you know i i
surely he doesn't mean to he just hasn't
been able to find work well he just you
know and because we love them we make
excuses for them that's right so how do
you help someone yes you love them it's
not love that's codependency okay
that is i am
my value in my world is through my
attachment to you and i'm willing to
just chain myself to your leg as we
drown yeah and what i want grace to know
is that you have more value than this
your kids need you and by the way you
knew this when you married him you saw
how he ran his business you knew they
weren't making any money that's why
you're making money you knew this
and here it is you got to pay the piper
and he does too my hope is that you
flipping the lights on and saying
enough's enough's enough's enough
that he will go oh thank god he'll step
it up i didn't know how to get out of
this either i was in quicksand and
grace saved me literally but it's time
it's time it's time it's time and to
answer your question if you're in a
relationship right now and your question
is but i mean your statement to yourself
is
but i love him or but i love her
she cheats on me he hits me he yells me
but i love her i don't that's not an
excuse anymore i don't care yeah you're
worth more than that yeah right it's
good
i just wanted you to say it out loud
oh man okay let's go to darcy out in
toronto hey darcy what's going on
everything
how are you good how are you
i'm doing great excellent what's up uh
yeah i have a question about how to
ensure that i can uh set my business up
for success in the long term
excellent bring it on uh
yeah so i own a small business my wife
and i own a
digital marketing agency we run it out
of our our home
and we've been doing it for uh two years
but i mean i've been uh doing this kind
of work for my whole life um probably
the last 10 to 15 years
and i you know i hear a lot of people
talk a lot everyone always says that you
want to own
a business and not own a job and i'm
pretty sure right now you would classify
us as owning a job i mean essentially if
i died tomorrow the
business would would collapse
um
so that aside
what what's so wrong about owning a job
if if we don't have um
goals for long-term growth or you know
massive growth and hiring a bunch of
employees and really building this thing
to something huge if we're comfortable
with the income that we make now the
hours we work and sustaining that maybe
growing it a little bit
is there anything really wrong with that
or am i like i just want to make sure
that we're on the right track yeah i
love this question darcy because um
people define success in
um
certain metrics as if that's the only
version of success like your version of
successes your top line revenue your
number of retail locations your number
of team members and that's not the only
way to define success i work with
business owners at all different stages
and and what i try to encourage them is
i want to help you define your version
of success so you can achieve it and if
that's 10 000 a year in a side gig to
pay for disney or if it's a million
dollars a year because you want to grow
this thing that's cool here's what i
would encourage you that is a benefit to
growing enough or scaling enough your
business model
so that you don't just own your job it's
so that you can take some time off and
still get paid so whether you scale your
business
in hiring team members that's not the
only way to scale it you could scale
your business and say i'm going to have
courses i'm going to have
multiple streams of income residual
income a subscription-based model where
darcy you could take a vacation
you could uh take fridays off and then
you're you got mailbox money money's
still coming in the business just is not
as dependent on you and so i would
encourage people to diversify their
their income sources for that reason
just so you've got more flexibility for
your life if you want to travel take a
vacation or if you get sick because when
you own your job if you're not working
you're not getting paid so that's the
benefit to that but yeah if you are
happy with your income and happy with
the business you the only version of
success that matters is your version of
success and so if this is success to you
then i think that you should do exactly
what you want to do if it's if it's
serving your life
in the way that you want it to that's
why we go into business anyway serve the
marketplace and for you to have the life
that you want it sounds like you're
doing it that's what i'm talking about
yeah your success is your success right
yeah
you get to decide what that looks like
and if you're doing it and somebody else
doesn't like it well they got their own
life their own business they know what
they want i do like
dave's picture which is he just takes
fridays off now yeah he's kind of cool
too
yeah all right it's another hour in the
books thanks christy thank you james
childs thank you kelly daniels we'll be
right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the ramsey headquarters
here in nashville tennessee broadcasting
from the dollar car rental studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
relationships your life and your money
i'm john dalone joined here by my good
friend and best-selling author christy
wright and we are taking your calls on
life and money relationships businesses
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to erica eric not erica regular old
eric but not right
we'll go to eric colombia hey eric
what's up good first off i love sex for
lovers that's a great song excellent and
secondly i just wanted to respond to the
other person and say
man in the mirror by michael jackson
i'm talking about the man in the mirror
i like that
that is every day you look that's
that's you
talking about yourself i love it man so
how can we help today thanks for calling
what's
up um i've just been dealing with i mean
i had a
divorce
um and then a two-year relationship
pretty much right after that that just
went completely downhill
um of course covid's been terrible
and i'm a handyman because i'm trying to
not work as much as possible
um to
take or like to be around my 10 year old
daughter
okay um i only get her like every other
weekend which is
so i can't work
those weekends and sometimes places when
you're in service industry they don't
want that and of course with kobe that's
just a difficult situation i mean i
paid for my college outright
um didn't enjoy what i was going to do
and i've just been struggling as far as
what
i really want to do i mean i'm 36 years
old
this friend of mine
told me
to pick up this life insurance
company
i mean i don't know what to do
honestly i mean get back to bartending
or i mean i can make good money
bartending or
what do you want to do man
what do i want to really do i would love
to teach children how to play golf
but that's twenty thousand dollars a
semester
for
the scga
in orlando florida and that would also
be
seven and a half hours away from my
daughter
okay so you've
you seem to have desires in your life
and then you immediately throw up
roadblocks as to why you can't have them
i want to have in one of the hottest if
not easily the hottest
handyman market of my lifetime
um yeah but the weekend stuff and some
people aren't gonna like this and i
really would love to do golf but that's
too far away that's too much money so
i'm not gonna do that and
you just you have these ideas and these
dreams and these hopes
and you know about looking in the mirror
you you told me the song right when the
call started
but there's something between you and
taking that action
is it a seri is it a years of being
burned are you just tired man
yes i actually ran for pretty much until
i was about 34 yep non-stop
and then when i had 35 i
just
i mean i was cutting down a tree with a
handful
um
and my ex-wife was not helping at all
with anything and in the yard
i mean i was doing everything
and then i mean i literally like pretty
much gave myself stroke i mean like yeah
i had to get i mean my dog was a service
dog
uh my blood pressure was like 210.
just your draw just
your spirit on the phone is a guy who is
just
cashed out
and then
you told me about this beautiful 10 year
old little girl that you got
oh yeah that you don't get to see enough
part of my dog those are the two things
that are keeping me
but i'm trying to stay motivated i got
you and here's what here's what i need
you to see
the best way you can honor that little
girl and love that little girl
is to love her daddy
the best way to love her dad pick her up
in about an hour
there you go
because right now she's absorbing this
brother
and i want you to find joy and i want
you to find peace i want you to find a
spark again and your spark's gone out
and life happened to you man life
happened to your heart
um yeah it's hit you in the mouth
but the question is
not all the things that happened that's
happened dude
and you'll spend years unwinding that
the question is
what are you gonna do today
that's right that's right
i mean i need to
hold on five minutes event and then just
no no no no
your body's been running and fighting it
for a long time man
you're tired it's okay to rest
it's okay to rest man
yes sir but you got to start loving eric
and you don't love eric right now you're
sick of eric
eric how much how much how much are you
working right now as a handyman how many
hours a week
i work as much as i possibly can for
today's department and
most of my clients are people that i
bartended for and i do
like pretty much anything i have the
tools to do
now how many hours
um
whenever they let me it depends on rain
i mean it's nope nope never take give or
take i would say
20 hours a week okay
that's one third of the amount of hours
you should be working how much money do
you make a year
um
that depends on the job but at the same
time i mean at one point like
about
six years ago i was making six figures
right now right and then right now i'm
making about
just
five
[ __ ] that 5 000 a year
no like
five figures a year
yeah but that could be ninety nine
thousand or nineteen thousand
right
i mean you could well i'm sorry like
less than eric how much money did you
make last year
last year i made
like 18 9. okay all right eric i
understand that you've had a hard time
you've gone through a divorce you had a
relationship that let you down you don't
get to see your daughter as much as you
want
but all i've heard on this call is
excuses
that people don't want you to work on
every other weekend that is bs
the handyman market is absolutely
exploding you could be making six
figures right now if you wanted to and
you could be making six figures in 40
hours a week if you wanted to you could
be absolutely rocking it which would
then the action would get you excited
again the money would give you
confidence again
it would change your whole outlook but
man you have got to stop sitting on the
couch and making excuses yes you've had
a hard time but you can change this now
none of those excuses you gave me of the
the market handyman
are valid none of them zero none of them
if you told me you were in the cruise
industry i'd be like all right it's time
to switch gears maybe you're in the
business that is absolutely exploding
you have to do something different if
you don't nothing's going to change john
deloney and i can't fix that for you man
you got to change your attitude you
gotta you can start loving that little
girl's daddy and get
after it
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
all right christine that i want to talk
about that last call we just had okay
um
he talked slow
he had lots and lots of excuses
and i let that call we let that call go
a little bit longer because i wanted to
dig in a little bit further and you and
i off air were talking about
um
just semantics and and language
i've always felt a difference between
physical tired i've been working 90 120
hours a week right and you mentioned you
said somebody comes in and goes john you
have to take a day off or your body will
quit on you right
and then there's tired
existential tired it's depression it is
your body is saying
we can't handle anymore we're
i'm out
and
the challenge is knowing
which one is which right which
i i i'm fatigued i've been just cranking
and cranking and cranking or i'm at
eighteen thousand dollars last year i
work a few hours a week
blah blah the challenge is that
existential tired
one of the chief solutions is connection
one of the chief solutions is
little wins doing stuff getting back out
there having a successful job that leads
to a successful job and getting it going
and going and going helps lift your
spirit you find purpose and so it's
that's the connection that me and you
and ken and dave all of our stuff starts
to talk about it all merges together
which is
those little bitty wins done over and
over leads to that full whole life and
so man talking to that guy
i'm telling him man you are tired
and i'm thinking existentially like life
has beat him up yeah
and the solution isn't to lay around
more yeah it's to get out there and get
going right well that's why i wanted to
ask because i was just sensing excuses
and you and i were saying this off air
but i was sensing that and that's why i
wanted to go straight to the
something measurable hey how many hours
a week are you working
well the rain no how many hours a week
are you working well people you know
their schedules know how many hours a
week even dodging the question like he's
not working
and so and living in the past how much
do you make well six years ago i don't
care though six years ago no right now
and so and so then it brought to light
even for him i hope oh man
i'm not working up and so i wanted the
listener for all the the people
listening right now i wanted to make
sure that they were hearing that that
you or me were not saying oh you're
tired take a vacation sit on your hands
some no no no that's not what you need
and i think what i was saying to you all
fair is i think the average person
doesn't discern the difference because
you have such a medical background you
know the differences here of what's
going on in the brain and the body but
the average person here is tired they
just think man you just you're just
tired and i was like he's he's he needs
he needs to get going
he needs to get going get going with
some gas after that's right so if if you
find yourself where you are just crushed
and you're feeling
i can't get out of bed
put two feet on the floor
and if you look in you're making
eighteen thousand dollars a year and you
think i can't make ends meet i'm sick of
it i'm tired
reach out and ask somebody hey you got
some work for me and you got some work
for me and i'll work in the rain and
i'll work on saturdays and i work on
sundays
and
if you work hard and you're pre person
that people want to be around you'll
find work especially in this crazy
market right
and man there's nothing that lifts the
human spirit like purpose like being
around other people and connecting with
them like doing a job that you need to
be there for and you do a great job it
all works together to lift the human
spirit man yeah
all right let's go to james in san
bernardino what's up brother james
yeah how you guys doing thank you for a
call outstanding what's up
man uh props to whoever puts the songs
uh tribe called quest that's great
that's ben hill over there took over for
james childs james doesn't play near
that good of music but ben ben rockstar
james is tired james i love it
uh chrissy i hope you uh thank you for
taking my call both of you i wanted to
very briefly um uh john uh uh dr john
christie um
ask you guys if my logic is sound
as you guys know um and i'll try to keep
this as brief as possible um house home
values are exploding uh here in
california they're still pretty high
back in 2017 a close family member of
mine
really pushed
and was recommending to my wife and
myself to purchase a home
that while we could afford the monthly
payments we weren't ready for
financially to do the purchase this is
pre-dave
pre-baby steps
now the house has exploded in value
this family member
gave us the money for the down payment
and money to fix it
when we mentioned to them the about
selling they uh
got offended
uh and uh they're a realtor and when we
were exploring the idea of hiring
someone else
it just it turned really messy
now
we're
i'm questioning my my thought process of
wanting to sell this house because you
sell the house sure you know where do
you go then you know rents here for a
two bedroom apartment are now
2500 where years ago it was
you know
more than a thousand dollar difference
um i want to know if if if you guys were
in this situation if you would consider
doing what
what we're thinking of which is to sell
just to
try to cut the cord on a possibly toxic
family relationship
man there's a lot here to this deal
um chrissy jump in any moment i'll i'll
talk through it recap the situation here
because we have a family member that's a
realtor that helped you buy this house
that you can afford the payments of but
they helped you with the down payment
you said
yeah this was uh this was four years ago
yeah so they feel like they can still be
speaking into your financial situation
you haven't paid them back
well i i would um
one of the stipulations was is that they
requested that if the house ever gets
sold that they want their money back
okay which okay fine you know yeah take
your money back we're still this this
jumps us from baby steps to into
possibly maybe even baby step 3b
um you know where would you live
where would you i'm sorry where would
you live uh so
currently uh uh well we would actually
move in temporarily with our in-laws
which isn't something that i really am
too
too excited about i love them very much
yeah and then what and then what
oh and then try to rent something
while we save up a down payment do you
all have any other debt
well
after after the sale no it'll wipe out
immediately no let's say that you don't
sell i'm just running some scenarios
here what debt do you have if you hold
on to the house
hold on to the house i would have uh
from 120 down to 78. so we have 78 000
left
most of which is student loans okay so
they gave you 50 ish
they gave us 80 80 000.
brother you're
man
you got a mess here um
on 15 different levels
and
even the fact that you're thinking about
doing something else that you haven't
thought through fully so you i want to
take them off the table you made a bad
house purchase i don't care if somebody
talked to you into it i want you to 100
okay so you made this call and they they
gave you 80 000
and
you're kind of in debt to them it's it's
a hovering debt that's just sitting over
you if you ever sell the house and i
want my money back and if you sell it in
five years and the market's gone
sideways you're going to owe them in
whatever it's a mess
and your solution to this mess is to
kind of jump into another situation
where you're gonna have to
move into the house of another family
member
so you're doing the exact same thing in
the exact same scenario just in reverse
yeah i want to run some scenarios where
you get out of the mess that you're in
and you don't get into a new mess it may
be a not a preferred situation you move
a little bit further out of town you
rent in a place that is not your
favorite neighborhood
but i agree i think going from one
indebtedness familial relationship into
another is not the way to solve this but
i do want you to get out from under
this weird
tangled
house i mean
it's just if you could have just paid
off their debt if you could have just if
they gave you 30 and you could just pay
it off in a few months i'd say keep the
house
pay off the family member and just be
done with the whole thing and keep your
house but it 80 is a lot for you to take
on in addition with other debt and you
have little kids
i have a um i have a three-year-old
daughter okay uh um my wife uh this this
family member would be on my side of the
family
uh going to in-laws
it is not ideal i i
[Music]
sell a house and do what you got to do
um don't move in with another family
member and complicate this thing further
sell the house pay off the debt pay off
the family member start saving for
another house and rent in between you'll
feel more free you need to get free
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john delaney
joined by my good friend christy wright
taking your calls on life and money
triple a two five five two two five
let's go to eric in wichita kansas hey
eric what's going on brother
hey guys i want to thank you for having
me uh
it's an honor you got yeah thank god
it's our honor too so what's up
i'm calling because uh uh we uh sold a
house uh this summer and bought a house
this summer uh we walked away with 100k
and um we uh allotted uh for a big down
payment um as you guys preach and to
keep that uh
mortgage insurance off and stuff like
that keep our payments down
and we did all that really good what
we're left though is with 42 000 of
student loan debt
17 000 on a uh
on an investment property that does
really well
for me
and uh
we have uh 45 000 in savings what should
i do should i pay it off
this year do i
if i wait till january first
not too sure
so you've got
you've got the forty thousand dollars in
savings and you have how much above and
beyond that from the house sale
um you know all we have left is just
fortunately
okay
gotcha yeah so we are going to
still walk the baby steps even though
it's you've had some you know home
purchases and that type of thing you're
still going to go through the baby steps
in order which is you're going to put
everything
that you've got which i know is scary
but everything that you've got except
for a thousand dollars at that debt
okay and i know that you're gonna be
debt-free right
yeah yes does it matter if i
go with the baby steps as far as lowest
to highest so i would pay the rental
property off first and then that would
leave me with only twenty thousand on
the
on the uh
how much is on the rental property how
much total debt do you have uh
total is um 57. yeah so we're still
gonna have a little bit left to tackle
after this um
what do you make a year man
dude what just lost
55 okay
what kind of investment property is this
um it's just a residential
okay
so you're about to have a debt-free
residential property as well
okay
i mean you could make you can make an
argument either way i mean you're so
close to becoming debt free you're not
going to have much left after you put
this 39 000 at it
if you want to
if you want you know that's the smaller
balance you can do that first and knock
it out if you want to
move that to the back line just because
of the different type of debt it is you
can but it doesn't matter you're going
to be out of debt very soon anyway so i
would take it i would just walk it in
order smallest to largest knock it out
and um and then and so what's the
largest balance remind me that
uh the 40 000 on the student loan
student loans so that's so what's what's
actually good about you doing this
investment property first and then not
go following them in order that student
loan is going to get on your nerves and
you're going to be fired up to want to
pay it off which is good versus if if
the last one was the investment probably
said oh well this is good
let's redo the bathrooms
i actually kind of like that get go
ahead knock that out so you don't have
that you know crutch to fall back on or
any temptation there that student loan
is going to irritate you enough to want
to pay it off and keep you on the plan
then you'll be debt free very soon and
uh and yeah you'll be having that income
you'll be doing great and eric that you
make 55 does that include that that
rental income
um
no that doesn't include the rental
income and i actually
i completely didn't include my wife's
income so together we we make uh 85.
yeah you should count her income always
well what's funny is i introduced her to
dave ramsey because she's a better dave
of course she is because she's smarter
than you than i am of course
so yeah um i want a hundred percent of
this rental income going to that student
loan and i want you all to just have for
christmas i want you all to get each
other
uh
john deloney's questions for human
questions for humans
you're gonna have great conversations
over christmas yes and it's 14.
very inexpensive presents i want you all
to make it a priority to just go gazelle
intense and get this nonsense paid off
get rid of this stuff um you should be
debt free by june of everything just be
done be done be done be done and um then
you're gonna you're gonna have turned a
major um financial corner in your life
that's just incredible yeah then you can
start building that savings back up i
know it's gonna be scary to get rid of
that savings towards the debt but you
can build it right back up after that
let's go to jordan in salt lake city
what's up brother
hi thank you so much for taking my phone
call you got it what's up
um so
my situation's a little complicated but
i'll just kind of break it down for you
um recently just sold one of the homes
that i owned
that my parents were actually living in
and i received a hundred thousand a
little over a hundred thousand dollars
from there um
the reason why it gets a little bit
complicated is because we have no other
debts
um
other than the other home that my wife
and i live in
which we have about 250 000 on
so i'm just trying to figure out kind of
what to do with that money and as well
as try to figure out potentially selling
the home we're currently in as well
and moving to a new location where
i split custody with my my ex-wife so
trying to just figure out what to do
with that situation
do you have any other debt
no nothing else okay we all cars are
paid off no student loans none of that
stuff you've got have you got any other
savings like a emergency fund or is that
it
yeah so we have about fifty thousand
dollars in savings minus the you know
not including the hundred thousand we
just received from our house so and
you're and you're are you investing
yeah yeah so we do we don't do i think
as much as what we should i just kind of
worked as a 401k
match yeah um so i think we do end up
about 10 a month or so when are you
thinking about moving
um the biggest thing is depends on the
situation um
with custody with my kids i've been
trying to fight
back and forth um to try to get custody
and they live right now about 40 minutes
away from us we've been looking to move
closer
and been thinking about selling our
house
buying another house which is difficult
for us because our goals are to pay off
our house and just live here
indefinitely
um so i would say if we were to move
about a year or so
maybe sooner okay
um
what we would recommend if you're
following the baby steps is to bump up
your investments to 15 that's going to
be an easy switch for you and it's not
going to make a huge difference in your
world um you could really go about it
one of two ways you can take that
hundred thousand dollars and put it on
your current mortgage just to bring that
down and you're not paying interest
between now and
a year from now if you move or if you
don't decide to move but you're still
gonna get the benefit of
that going towards whatever you move the
only other thing that gives me a slight
pause is um
if you're in that custody battle um the
expenses of that and attorneys fees and
the unknown so if you want to hold back
more
of that hundred thousand and bump up
your emergency fund to be larger than
what a normal person might need of three
to six months of expenses because you're
really preparing for
whatever these costs could be then
you're welcome to do that as well
because you if you don't use it then you
have the cash when you move to put as a
down payment on the house so i think you
could i think you could go about that
either way and i'm glad you got it you
know i'm glad you got it for that reason
for when you're going through something
so hard like that i if if i'm moving in
a year i would put this money in a in a
high yield savings account you're not
going to make a bunch of money on it but
you're not going to lose any of it it's
just going to sit there
and like christy said it'll be liquid if
you if you have an event
um if you're going to stay in this if i
was struggling two three four or five
years then yeah i would pay the i'd go
ahead and pay the mortgage off
or pay it down yeah yeah yeah so so one
other option i had to talk to my i just
refinanced the
um pretty good interest rate
and what i'm trying to figure out is
like they said if i put down
x amount of dollars like 50 000 i'll
actually re
do something basically where they go off
that now new value of the interest
versus
so it's like 200 000 is what i would owe
essentially instead of 250
and they would redo the the rate off of
that and so now you're going to change
this
yeah or it would be essentially less yes
yeah so you're i mean you're dealing
with nickels and dimes if you're talking
about 10 to 12 months
um if you're going to be in this house
three to five years then yeah that makes
sense put 50 in a high yield savings
account put 50 down on your mortgage and
get it to 200 i mean
at this point it's 6.5 dozen another
since you're about to move and since
you're in the middle of a custody battle
i personally would rather stay liquid
during the custody battle and as
mobile as possible if i'm going to
upsell this house
[Music]
it's good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is
philippians 4 12.
i know what it is to be a need and i
know what it is to have plenty i've
learned the secret of being content in
any and every situation whether well-fed
or hungry whether living in plenty or in
want
coretta scott king says i am fulfilled
in what i do
i never thought that a lot of money or
fine clothes the finer things of life
would make me happy
my concept of happiness is to be filled
in a spiritual sense
love it alright let's go to david in
dallas texas hey david what's up
hi
thank you for taking my call you bet
thanks for calling us what's going on
dude how can we help
hi um so i've been listening to the show
for about a year now
and i'm getting ready to start to pay
off my student loans all right
thank you um so i'm 26 and i have around
83 000 in student loans okay um
and i have the uh thousand dollar
emergency fund and i'm i've been using
the every dollar budget app excellent
yeah so i've watched a lot of student
debt related videos in the youtube
channel
and
it's a little weird but i'm kind of
excited to
pay it off because i think i i i know
that i can pay
faster yeah absolutely
yes
get this cancer out of your life my
brother
yeah um so
my question is um as it gets closer to
january um i'll be using the death
snowball of course um
i was wondering if i should start paying
it off now or save as much money as
possible
and pay a huge chunk on january
why would you do that
why would i
save
yeah like why would you save up and wait
until january to start versus just
putting the money that you have on it
now as you have it
um
i was thinking about that too but uh i
got an email that says i
um i've uh
that
i start paying on january
start paying today yeah
yeah
you don't
you may have got an email that says you
don't have to start paying until january
but here's what we want to do you want
to start this process as soon as
possible
not just for the interest and not just
for the financial you're going to get
benefit from it the sooner you start to
knock it down but for your own self for
your own motivation for your own sense
of progress of like i'm doing this wow
that felt good now i'm going to put next
month more on it more on it man when you
get that momentum going it's going to
motivate you to keep going if you wait
it's you might stall out you might spend
some money over christmas like we're
going to start today i don't care what
the email said we're going to start
today and then you'll go ahead and get
it get it started even faster you got it
okay yes
we're with you brother congratulations
man this is awesome awesome awesome
all right if you haven't if you uh
speaking of student loans if you aren't
strapped with student loan payments odds
are you know someone who is we do david
millions are putting their lives on a
hold they can't buy a house or have kids
because they're stuck or even worse
they're waiting waiting waiting for the
government to save them with student
loan forgiveness what a joke our team
has produced a new documentary called
borrowed future and it is out now it
uncovers the dark side of the student
loan industry and exposes how the system
is built to work against you you'll see
dave ramsey weigh in on epic failure
otherwise known as the student loan
program along with featured interviews
from industry leaders and thought
leaders like seth godin seth fratman and
john deloney who's that guy we're coming
at this hard folks taking big swings at
the student loan problem with the goal
to arm parents and students across the
country with the truth you don't have to
take out loans to get a college
education it's available on apple tv
amazon prime video google play or go to
borrowed future dot
com let's go to pedro in austin texas
right down the street what's up man
hey how you doing outstanding how's how
are you
pretty good man i have a simple question
so i'm uh upside down on a car no i was
uh pretty young at the time didn't
realize what i was doing until it was
done
um i owe about 15 to 18 000 on a car no
under two vehicles if so it's
consolidated and one of them is not
working
i wanted to see how can i work
uh a tour to paying my debt off
and see what y'all had know what kind of
advice you had for me what other debt do
you have
um i have a
like a little loan with about
600 loan with a financing company and i
believe that's about it
like i said uh
the main thing i'm trying to get rid of
is this car knows is just i'm trying to
stay uh motivated to pay it off which is
sometimes it seems kind of hard to do
sure okay so tell me again how much you
owe it's two cars that you've
consolidated yes it's it's two cars
consolidated on one note okay and the
total of the note
it's about um 16 to
18 grand
okay and what are the cars worth both of
them uh
one of them is like i'm not sure like i
said i'm upside down one of them's at
old four the other ones of 2008.
so like one of them is actually down in
the shop and the other one's barely
hanging on what are you driving right
now
um
right now i'm not driving anything i'm
i'm actually a truck driver so i'm not
even using them at the moment but i'm
saying one of them's down
my fiance is using the car right now
because we have
two kids and she works as well
yeah how much do you make a year brother
um
i haven't been at this job too long
because um i would shoot for i'm back
about
15.
i just lost you still there brother
about
1500 to 2 000 every two weeks okay so
i'm not sure what it is a year about 4
000 a month okay
so first thing i want you to do is this
when we asked you how much are on these
car notes you said uh 16 to 18
i want you to know exactly
what
you're shackled um well before
i i looked up on the app but last time i
looked it was 16 000 but it was not my
payoff it's an interest-bearing loan
right as well so i want to know what
this this amount is in the same 16 000.
i want all of you i want you to take all
of your debts
i want you to list them in order of
smallest to largest that 600 you're like
uh maybe i don't it's about 600 i want
you know exactly who you owe and how
much
and right now it's all kind of fuzzy in
your head it's a little amorphous it's
just this and it's kind of weighing me
out and i'm not driving that car i don't
know exactly how much i owe i'm gonna
take ownership of this money
and then i'm gonna start swinging it i
want you to get pissed off at this these
two loans one's in a broke car that
won't even drive and one's barely
hanging on you got two kids and i want
you to get angry at this thing
crush it
be done with this forever
no believe me
i'm done with uh loans i'll tell you
that i know i know but right now you're
like you're done can you sell them can
you sell the one the one that's broken
can you can you just i just don't even
want you to look at it get something if
you've got the one car that your wife is
using
then that's fine because she's using it
but even just the eyesore of this of
like this reminder of what's going on
sell it get a little bit of money put
that towards it attack the 600 get rid
of that and then get after this loan
with unbelievable intensity because
you're gonna have to like th this is so
discouraging to you because you're
upside down in it having a loan on a car
is not fun anyway but having a loan on a
car that's not worth that is like
unbelievably defeating so i want you to
knock this out not just for the
financial benefit but for your own just
sense of morale yeah and it's and it's a
i hate to say it like this i wish it was
a nicer way to say it but it's a stupid
text you did something dumb
we've all done it
oh my gosh my dumb is way more than 16
000 dude so this is this is a slap on
the wrist but it stinks right it's a
chunk of your income the next two years
it's not fun
and it's just a stupid tax i'm not ever
you've learned your 16 000 lesson you're
never going to do this again so let's be
done with loans get raged out on this
thing drive trucks deliver papers in the
morning work chick-fil-a on the weekends
i don't care what you got to do get this
thing out of your life
sell one of these cars pitch that 150
bucks or 500 bucks for a thousand bucks
you get get bananas after this thing and
just start moving you got this pedro and
i love
never taking out a loan again
never thanks for hanging out with me
this is fun it was a good day you did
good he did good questions for humans
questions for human johndolone.com
ramsolutions.com i want to thank
producer james childs and associate
producer kelly daniel
and you america for staying with us
we're so grateful for you be kind to one
another and we'll see you soon on the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]